the leftists that now dominate the
democrat party
hate just about everything associated
with american tradition
from flags to monuments to even
christianity
which is why it was bitterly ironic that
joe biden should communicate
his latest ideological purge during an
appearance
at the national prayer breakfast
we just have to open our eyes we've just
witnessed images that we've never
imagined images that now we'll never
forget
a violent assault in the u.s capitol on
our assault on our democracy
on our capital a violent attack that
threatened lives and took lives
we know now we must confront and defeat
political extremism
white supremacy and domestic terrorism
well using the capitol hill riots of
course as the justification
i knew it was only a matter of time
until biden and his administration
would turn their sights on the us
military
now biden's pentagon chief has announced
we mentioned this briefly last night
when it broke
a stand down of all u.s military forces
in order to scour the ranks for
so-called extremists
now lloyd austin the new secretary of
defense hinted at a possible
purge during his confirmation hearing
i will fight hard to stamp out sexual
assault and to rid our ranks of racist
and extremists the job of the department
of defense is to keep america safe from
our enemies
but we can't do that if some of those
enemies lie within our own ranks
of course well what he really meant then
and what he would
like to do now is rid the military
of all strong conservatives and of
course trump supporters
now think of all the challenges america
is facing at this moment
with the rise of china especially and
this
is what our defense chief is focused on
now reuters is reporting that the biden
administration doesn't even have a plan
for how to conduct its so-called review
or
what the stand down would even mean or
look like
but one thing is for sure if this is
substantive
and not symbolic it will do grave damage
to our military preparedness and morale
our men and women in uniform have been
asked to sacrifice
multiple tours many of them for so long
and oftentimes ridiculous engagements
idiotic wars and now the biden
administration rewards them
by casting them as potential domestic
terrorists
ticking time bombs of white supremacy
you can always count on think tank
generals whose salaries are funded by
rich donors
to side with the democrats on an issue
like this
like thomas claudettes a retired army
brigadier general
who told fortune magazine he's really
worried about the enemy within
saying we're probably talking about
thousands across the department of
defense
many of them will have already run their
mouth put things on social media
now people like him will claim that it's
fine for defense personnel to have
strong political views that are
conservative
but in practice we already know how this
is all going to play out
look at how fast the national guard
moved against its own ranks after the
capital riot
apparently vetting more than 25 000
national guardsmen
removing a dozen or so from inaugural
duty some on dubious grounds by the way
so you post something on facebook about
i don't know standing for the national
anthem at football games and the next
thing you know
you can be labeled a white nationalist
you text a friend about how you think
trump stood for the forgotten man and
woman
and you're practically a kkk member
if democrats were really concerned about
stamping out extremism
they'd be looking in the mirror how many
wacky
incendiary inflammatory defamatory
hateful things
have been said by their members over the
past five years or heck just over the
past month
we should devote just an entire show
just to left-wing extremism
which runs the gamut from antifa to blm
to open border zealots who think we're
all living on stolen land
and where were biden and friends when
islamic radicals infiltrated our
military ranks during the war on terror
now thankfully some of these attacks
were thwarted but many innocent
americans were also killed
the muslim convert who killed a u.s army
recruiter in little rock arkansas
the army private arrested and charged
with allegedly plotting an
attack at fort hood pfc nasser abdul
was arrested at a motel in killeen texas
police say a muslim american muhammad
abdulaziz
opened fire at two military centers
killing four marines and a sailor
the fbi is investigating the pensacola
shooting as an act of terror why the
gunman's time in saudi arabia
is being examined okay sometimes we
forget
that all of this happened where were the
calls for the immediate
vetting of all troops with connections
to islamic extremist groups
now i was doing this on radio every day
during most of this time period and not
only did democrats not demand that type
of vetting
they accused us of islamophobia for even
raising concerns
racially profiling predominantly muslim
neighborhoods it's wrong it's
counterproductive
it's dangerous republican hopefuls need
to come out
and be against this kind of islamophobia
it's our responsibility to reject
proposals that
muslim americans should somehow be
treated differently it would be an even
greater tragedy if our diversity becomes
casualty here
well diversity unless of course it means
respecting the opinions and beliefs of
conservatives
or devout christians or other religious
denominations
instead of lecturing us about the
importance of tolerance
like they did back then leftists are
gleefully calling for an
ideological cleansing of the ranks
what do you make about this through line
of military service and white supremacy
i was thinking the guard is 90 some odd
percent
i believe male uh
only about 20 percent of white males
voted for biden
anybody who cannot pledge allegiance
to to their mission
and may be pulled by other views
they need to be removed from the guard
safety has to be our first priority
safety for whom it's certainly not going
to make america safer
having the military turn to an arm of
the dnc
what about the military members of faith
or who vote republican
i mean you heard you had the reference
to oh they're all men
white men so if you're a white male
christian
maybe you voted republican maybe even
like trump you're immediately suspicious
you're
a suspect how are any of those people
supposed to feel safer now of course
they're not going to feel safe
so what's the real goal here preventing
any dissent
in the country when their policies
slowly but surely
are depriving us of liberty and
prosperity
well do the democrats plan more
lockdowns for coronavirus mutations
the requirement for vaccine certificates
for travel are they
worried that members of the military are
going to side with the constitution
instead of crazy social justice warriors
who want to remake america and even
remake the military
finally a message to the republicans
like liz cheney
this is your opportunity to show
everyone that you'll fight harder
against the democrats
than you do against donald trump refuse
to allow a single
u.s taxpayer dollar to fund this
ideological
and un-american purge of the u.s
military
or expect a lot of us to push for steep
cuts in military spending
after all why should we fund an
organization that democrats plan to use
not to protect us but to restrain us
in order to protect themselves and their
grip on power
and that's the angle